ragazzi buongiorno ciao a tutti ho la
come potete vedere la mia faccia io non
ho dormito ma non avreste dovuto dormire
nemmeno voi perché oggi verrà a bussare
alle nostre porte ragazzi oggi
finalmente parte il willy o quello che
volevo fare io era trovare un modo
fattibile di poter celebrare questo
momento insieme a chi veramente ne segue
è insieme a chi veramente avrebbe
piaciuto e insieme a chi è veramente
avrebbe apprezzato di condividerlo con
me non so che cosa possa succedere sono
gasato terrorizzato stanco euforico allo
stesso momento
forse così che si muore in età precoce 3
è appurato che la mia famiglia sia
scemano ma perché un megafono perché
abbiamo un megafono ragazzi qualcuno
deve farla stare zitta per quelli a
migliaia ragazzi dobbiamo andare tardi
andiamo
allora cos'è il buio nei guai hanno
un'idea che è venuta a me ha tutto il
mio meraviglioso team ossia invece di
fare cose assurde perché non facciamo la
cosa più semplice il milione e sono
tante persone senza le quali questo
traguardo non sarebbe mai stato
possibile e quindi forza cosa più facile
per ringraziarle e quello proprio di
ringraziarle dal vivo allora la prima
persona da cui andremo si chiama chiara
e abitano posto che si chiama tipo conio
tipo vecchio conio una ballerina che
parla i caraibici salsa bachata merengue
kizomba ed è appena tornata da
un'esibizione che cronin a una cosa che
il forestiere a guglielmo che lo stimo
tantissimo termine youtuber presento il
mondo è colui che segue da più tempo e
più volentieri lo stimo non per quello
che fa ma per quello che è in tutto e
per tutto ma con mia mamma mi ha detto
una cosa così grazie chiara
sto provando ad abbracciarti anzi a da
per baciarti un coniglietto in casa
chiara stiamo arrivando
[Musica]
no
io non ero nero oppure nero per amore
perdono ben presto
no dico così bella guardati
coloratissimi 10 mi ha appena detto che
loro non compro via tasso per me
supermercato
[Musica]
così tanto per detto no
sentitelo però adesso vedremo alcuni
sono però vogliamo farci firmare da
tutte le persone che incontriamo la la
bandiera spiegato abbastanza bene ha
chiamate con mandato una mail ciao maria
sì
[Musica]
bellissimo il carini
la prima tappa si è conclusa volevamo
rimanere in realtà tutta la vita da
chiara imbarco a mangiare susine
albicocche e accarezzare il dolce
coniglio rem warren brand maremma e
quando dormi appunto fase rem e nemiche
un coniglio che ti per accollare la
notte visto che siamo in zona abbiamo
pensato di prendere pure una piccola
deviazione per andare a salutare un
amico che conosco in realtà da un bel po
di tempo su internet e finalmente a
battere questa barriera che ci ha
separato
fino ad oggi che era il telefono e la
distanza soprattutto giusto per
salutarla di un abbraccio e poi
proseguire verso andiamo genova la
liguria la liguria e proseguire verso
genova
la liguria linea sei pronto ad andare
certo sono nato pronto di questo sin
dalla gara di danza
ragazzi siamo arrivati a cerreto guidi e
storico tra jacopo meglio e sono un po
emozionato sera nella bandiera era
attaccato la bandiera ragazzi allora la
bandiera giusto non era a vendere giusta
non mi mettono dietro nel qual è la
bandiera giusta nessuno qui capisce
no ragazzi non ho parole enrico che
dimentica il ricco e poi non so se non
ti amo cioè provvidamente ce ne siamo
resi conto chirico oggi è miss maglietta
bagnata in realtà con pure una
bellissima partita cerca l'argine
salve non ci fa nell ascolto no sei
giovane mancino me sfondi a marradi
panna
noi però quando non indicato zuccherino
almeno posso giocare prima perché no la
fanno sorridere sapere cosa mangia un
bruto cosa mi metto che non può farsi
daniele non sapevo cosa non limitato
niente
mandiamo 39 come verona onlus e la
vorrei chiamare qualcosa col treno mi
piacerebbe
sa dire non l'avrete di impatto tipo
vorrebbe dentro non funzionerebbe non
sempre i dolci offerti non scappiamo
prima vicini perse tale tesi
ma se non c'è sotto qualcosa vabbè
rimaste come se ci sta dimenticando
tutto
grazie ciao sono un gel ma siccome se
come pellegrini creda fermarci a cena
sei sicura al cento per cento
ecco
non possiamo ce ne andiamo a cena chiara
da tutti a cena da chiara abbiamo pure
svoltato la cena di voler o il tempo e
sarò già da terra
ragazzi siamo a uscio in provincia di
genova che c'è scusate se vi era un po
durante il tragitto volevo dirvi che
quando arrivate a uso dovete prendere il
primo di via sulla sinistra e crossa una
piazzetta con lei parcheggi parcheggio
norme proprie io la amo già ragazzi che
avrebbero parcheggiato stiamo arrivando
stiamo rimandiamo chiara gara dove sa è
chiara hai detto che per i gatti
ciao chiara pia chiara è la chiara
[Applauso]
uno tecnologico nitrati sono chiari come
stai
chiara si è detto che c'erano gatti ma
questi campioni perché con esso un gatto
[Musica]
ero a casa senza delle grida e meno
della gente scenderà con la bandiera
perciò io sono al presidente sia la loro
marcia con una bandiera gridando ci sono
loro ti prego che mi darà soddisfazioni
gigante sensi arrivata a casa mi devo
far la doccia gli asciugamani da
stenderà e lui dice ha detto chiaro che
arrivano quattro possibili titoletto
laveno siamo in quanto c'è anche chiara
va bene non ho altri quattro giudici
bene soprattutto lì si balletto
io vado a comprare per ora basta
primavera come si scrive ma viva viva
bene la pasta primavera gli ho detto ma
che è la pasta vita gli dissi ma certo
ha detto di dire una volta al mese
una volta al mese televisivo lei ha
fatto quello che gianmarco definisce
ordini di silvio che se tocchi una cosa
rischi di prendere il colera
però io non so se l'abbiamo detto no
però la cosa che c'è più piaciuta
dichiara che ha scritto abito in un
paesino dove ci sono più gatti che
persone ragazzi siamo abbiamo messo
piede qua o ci fosse stato un mio
allievo la simpatia dei gatti caffè
buona tela tale idea io la matematica lo
sai cosa vuoi questo è un'equazione a
venire per vedere lei non è un attrice
ma dieci mesi fa ero al festival della
carica questa ombra che ha in testa
sei tu dieci mesi fa erano altresì al
della comunicazione è un suo amico viene
da me mi disse fai un videomessaggio a
questa mia amica è perché vederlo video
vero successo dopo alberto campagna e la
figlia del vice sim
giuliano carabinieri
[Applauso]
non parlare con le forze dell'ordine
ragazzi ho appena visto una lucciola
anzi una lucciola più bella purtroppo so
bene che scomparsa si è spenta viva e
aprite di risulta
[Musica]
[Applauso]
allora lui è che il ragazzo dichiara
[Musica]
scusami
oddio con chi stai capisco la via del
vigile no no la mia gestione
incidente allora ragazzi siamo stanchi
morti la prima giornata è finita ci
mette a dormire non c'è più
anzi se vi dico no il giorno dopo e
stiamo andando a pavia
siamo in macchina e stiamo andando a
farci rapinare perché di colpo e buio
tutto quanto ma dove sei
noi siamo ragazzi stava andando a
trovare laura paesino che si chiama
tornio
i brani proni un'azienda vinicola ed ama
la natura va spesso in montagna per
sciare anche nel periodo estivo
mazzari godot sia sul terriccio
devo chiedere francia cristiana martino
sentina proverbi anche noi cosa classi
tranquilla non sei ristoranti giornale
che sono martina come si può notare dal
numero produci tutti però diciamo che
mangiamo un intero per forza partito
lenta l'amica mancano perché è un
ragazzo
a broni dai bravi che carina dal bravo
piccola pausa per mangiarci una cosa
stavo andando da chiara a putin per
poterti dire che mi ha regalato al sacco
dei momenti bellissimi soprattutto con
della triste perché sempre più persone
in più perché sarebbero passate aspetti
presi in campo per quello che posso dire
dei video e diciamo che non mi sono
persa uno per tutti che cosa quando mi
incontra dal vivo se ci sarà il lido non
sa se si ricorderà di medico e di como
invece ti sei iscritto con l'altro
ospite cielo
in realtà è sempre ospite artico è
sempre uno spirito l'anno solare
andiamo andiamo verso forlì
[Musica]
all
tutti
[Musica]
stiamo bene
qual è la verità
smettere di guidare per 5 minuti e
guglielmo stata l'uscita messo di milano
anzi sono raddoppiati di lidia dinos
coperchio via
saluti come sempre ci siamo appena
salutati che posso dire basta ai una
voce pure ragazzi e michela ci sta
portando in un posto dove c'è
praticamente un cartello che dice
vietato l'accesso ai cani anche se al
guinzaglio e che dicono praticamente in
questo qui sia il parco di conigli e che
i coniglietti possono pagare in giro
tranquillamente
dove sono i coniglietti non me ne vado
finché non ero io poi mi apprezzano in
cui la coppa ragazzi cinquina teocoli io
ho buttato con ios
ma non puoi correre ciccone appena
mandata stella enrico col coniglio non
vuole avere a che fare con te marco il
documentario ne ho appena visti 34 st
persone ma è un bidone prezzi e un
quarto pieno di conigli c'è nel senso mi
sembrava chiaro la descrizione che è
stata data che si sono salvati
chi vuol dire attacca nico sono erbivori
ma no ai conigli e non sono animali
anche pericolosi con i velociraptor
forse quelli domestici sono più
pericolosi forse sta per scoppiare una
rissa coniglio contro un rapace la
nutria cento quella che succede così
eccola
un ragazzino mi giocherò in acqua e la
mamma vorrebbe il messaggio altre specie
diverse di animali che riescono a
convivere insieme l'uomo e l'uomo di
tutta la stessa specie non riesce spesso
a farlo infatti se c'è qualcosa di
terribile
sappiatelo ok che sono i miei piani
i miei piedi papa
[Applauso]
grazie
grazie a te grazie ragazzi e gianmarco e
terrorizzato per i conigli ha paura che
li accettiamo guarda che i conigli hanno
un quoziente intellettivo più alto del
giusto ora sono loro che assaltano bene
stiamo andando arrivi di questa sera
beccheremo un po più di persone ancora
capire come fare ma sono sicuro che ci
proviene un modo dobbiamo farcela
ragazzo e solo in secondo giorno non
possiamo mollare mai
adesso devo farci un giro prima se c'è
qualche persona che abbiamo così ha
raccattato su instagram
fatemi tenderemo a dormire presto
ma scusa perché secondo te lo stesso
cielo canale ma
lui erano le saline
ormai io lo metto questo debito non
voglio 700 puntare voglio fare un
sondaggio ma il vero
lasciate un commento così facendo loro
sapere ci tornerò e lo farò siamo in
periferia siamo sul lungomare è diviso
per rimasto qui arriva mamma
adesso vorrei da tutti una cosa un po
più
per fare
girate
siamo appena tornati in albergo
siamo fuori con terminato per strada
sono dei 213 stiamo morendo di sonno ci
vediamo veramente fra i due secondi
giorno numero 3 ci dirigiamo verso
l'umbria si viaggia veloci sulla paura
o no
siamo freschi in realtà grazie
cosa ci dicono a cannes e guiglo rimani
a perugia magna la cioccolata gli
spiriti degli amanti preferiscono
indugiare tra i sogni si fa più concreto
un giorno con tenerezza amato una nota
d'oro adesso è intenzionato ad esso
adoro signore ha bisogno di ozio
inquietante smetti di mangiarci ma sai
che comunque si vede la differenza
siccome five io adesso come mi facevi
prima che si vede in sé più sano
se fai conto che io ho sempre detto io
non conosco pugliano oscilla conosco qui
il guscio perché era il personaggio del
chieri 3 auto su internet invece adesso
ovvio non è che conosciamo il 100 per
cento certo no però conosciamo più buio
all'uscita adesso quello che percepisco
fatevi un leggero velo davanti c'era da
santa maria degli angeli è tutto a
questo punto noi passiamo per magia in
realtà davanti a questa bellissima
chiesa
sì non so perché non l'abbia vista prima
credo che sia la chiesa di santa
marie saint marie angelorum importi non
so leggerlo il latino
si no
ciao ciao massimiliano no se vengono qua
mi faccio esplodere tra l'altro una
challenge per voi mi dovete guardare il
primo che arriva a camper serico
concentrazione concetrazione l'angolo
rosso e non prospetta vince il primo
biglietto o non rido ma qui ci sono le
cascate delle cascate delle sono le
cascate più alte del dell'europa io
facevo venire con lui ma non ci siamo
mai venuti ucciderà sarà di fatto
[Risate]
a bagnarsi carenze
saia prezzo nei pressi di una cascata
[Musica]
siamo appena arrivate l'aquila vi chiedo
scusa se sono un po rallentato di giro
che non sta dormendo adesso prendiamo
mangiarci arrosticini vi prego
c'è una voglia di arrosticini che mi si
porta via
[Musica]
in realtà mi dispiace un sacco non
riuscire a visitare tutte quante le
famiglie o magari dei ragazzi vittime
del sisma che c'è stato in passato cioè
non che non ci abbia provato ci ho
provato a contattare varie inerzie
svariate associazioni non c'è purtroppo
risposta nessuno quindi diciamo che
l'unione se possiamo fare camminare
guardare quello che che c'è quello che
il terremoto ha lasciato senza una guida
e questo caso un pochino ci dispiace
ciao e auguri a te 4
noi siamo guidate alla fine scorso
nessuno di quanti grazie a tutti per
essere soprattutto precari di sergente
appunto come disse un giorno diventerà
un mondo perfetto per dirci addio con
trento
addio
e ci sono i dottorati ragazze che stiamo
stufando
così
non possiamo confondere sono stati visti
dentro la mente non benissimo ma perché
si scusa poi abbandonato il posto di
lavoro e lazio altro in cui napoli
non facciamo arrivare ai furti che
parlano invece che cosa può che sentirsi
studenti allora stata nero son finiti
ma chissà se biodinamica di lettere
ingegneria medicina senza te cliente e
di design e con e attesi a torino vero
caso ci permette primo decennale a suo
tempo l'ho fatta sul la differenza delle
persone che si porta nei sogni o meno
perché c'è chi ricorda di più su ogni
aspetto dai ragazzi lì dentro
fatene una con l'indice destro in su che
ti riprendi bene per l'attesa scusate
per poco tempo
ciao ciao ragazzi sono appena arrivati
in albergo volevo solamente dire una
cosa perché stasera ma proprio riempito
il cuore c'è luigi amore ti posso
normale fra i due secondi fra due
secondi per favore signori quello che
volevo dire io è che bellissimo poter
ricambiare l'affetto che ti viene dato
per chiarire ricevo tantissimo e stasera
ieri sera il primo giorno è stata una
roba incredibile e mi sento veramente
fortunato detto ciò facciamo una
velocissima precisione a domani ok siamo
in molise a venafro e stavo per andare a
incontrare una ragazza che purtroppo ci
ha chiesto di non portare le videocamere
all'interno della sua abitazione perché
papà e mamma non vogliono quindi
fondamentalmente quello che faremo è un
giro attorno per dimostrare che il
molise esiste questo è un piccolo
arbusto del molise questa invece è una
ringhiera del molise
e questo accade del molise di
spegnimento intellettuale
alcuni disabili
vero
amato io sotto l'occhio per minutino
il pericolo
dove stiamo andando
direzione giffoni
[Applauso]
adesso qui mi lanciava delle cannonate
preparate non so come fare i numeri che
non era abituato visto cucchietti contro
loro due
eravamo 5 non a sparare sulla croce
rossa
[Applauso]
ragazzi siamo un pochino stanchi o
fondamentalmente è la prima volta dopo
quattro giorni che facciamo veramente un
pasto dall'inizio alla fine
mangiando tutto quanto e quindi non
abbiamo ripreso la che avevamo fame come
disse il budget è arrivato adesso il
momento di darci una notte perché
appena finito il pulito giorno
l'audio
william
e quindi è uguale al giorno
willy quinto giorno siamo a salerno
faremo un giro qui in zona perché c'è
una ragazza che possiamo trovare poi ci
spostiamo da tutt'altra parte perché è
arrivato il momento della puglia andiamo
tremaglia vestire note come ne celava
vicine guarda sbancato tipico ragazzo
questa cosa qui è tipicissima tutti i
pali c'è proprio anzi concertatore pio
xii strazianti noi
faccio mio
si stanno scendendo visto mazzoni e anni
fa precisa che è uscita la struttura del
nord su facebook no e quindi detto ma tu
immaginati che culo che una volta del
cerchio giovani che lo trovo a casa io
mando del form dicendo alla mia
fidanzata
c'è una cosa mangiato anche tu che
massimo ha pure giocato che la regione
per le piacevo la mamma aspetta di pasta
una persona aspetta un attimo anche
nella antonella pronto giorgia
c'è tua mamma che sta tornando a casa
che così da quello cha giulia e si sia
uscito sono messo che vuoi non me lo
dici innanzitutto lui terrificante
ammazza che esce dell'inganno della
morte guardi quando lo riproponiamo
quella foto che appoggiare la tosse tipo
non so perché una scoliosi
quindi cosa mi consiglia che tuttavia
brava si sta facendo troppo ridere
nove anni dopo questo lo zuccotto
[Musica]
materna
e del cioccolato che non soci
[Risate]
come vedete come
[Musica]
abbiamo appena lasciato il siria e
abbiamo aperto instagram che un botto di
persone sono venute posto in cui abbiamo
coperto praticamente questo segmento di
giornata e quindi abbiamo deciso di fare
un salto al volo a mare bellissimo ci
lanciamo saluti da me e poi andiamo
verso bari ciao
grazie ciao
mi tengo ora qui sta un po facendo il
cose ma lui
su
allora ti ricordi il video dei macarons
ho pianto quando hai pubblicato il video
dei pesci d'aprile chiuso il canale di
aver chiuso il canale vorrei
ringraziarti per meritate per gli
insegnamenti dovete venire a trovarmi
perché voglio un po di famiglia ha
scelto nella mia demo enrico però perché
la mia ragazza è persa di e potrebbe
rubarmela con un cuore giovane ragazza
enrico è un cassonetto
[Musica]
arriva col tuo nome donato 6 stato
selezionato grazie
[Musica]
ciao ciao
siamo arrivati a casa di dorato giusto
due aperture siamo trovati a tutti che
sarei finito e non ridevo di questa cosa
esco del tour ma lavorano e mail team
bondi il mou se lo ritrova quale furono
tifosi e divertito perché lo sono
davvero dicendo a tutti
mi fermo rispondo dopo 1 ora
mi telefonò numero sconosciuto era tipo
hakim dalla vodafone albania è un altro
terminale
qui sono arrivati di sms cosicché non
succedevano da maicon numeri strani che
io ho nicotra iran il terrore che foste
voi risveglio voi a dormire giustamente
il mio tipo sveglio dalle 6 mb così così
con il ticca le storie quando però visto
il numero non ho pensato foste gori
pronto si gioca a dio per bertolaso di
nuove ma se dovrà essere qui a
prescindere poi ha preso impegni le
continuava a dire ma guardate in quella
settimana wilbur shaw nel milione verrà
sicuramente l grazie maschile così io
con gliel'ho detto lei disperata e il
faccio a tema scusa ti faccio salutare
prima trovare pure quelli che facevano
ma tu non capisci cosa non capisco e le
regole ma la storia lista grande amico
oddio adesso in qualità di enrico mai
capite o andare a parigi e le caminate
anziano appunto si blocca io tipo ho ma
qui ci sono dubbi è lei no pansera
nessuna storia è innamoratissima lei si
chiama sarà di salutare per favore c'è
mi lascia lì dove favore non facciamo
sarà non vuoi raccontare della nostra
redazione
se mettiamo insieme ma cosa fa guarda
dentro beckett una vita non fosse adatto
o no questo chi è palerà c'entra niente
è troppo bello per cui qui diciamo
avevano queste paure e poi la tattica
visto il colonnello diciamo 6 si apparto
prima volta e ci siamo innamorati di
teora ogni volta che pubblici una storia
noi celati comandiamo sumo sap per
gridare il topless e lo dice un angelo
che sia bello mi è sembrato non facciamo
diciamo hai fatto cambiare idea
che impatto nodi che grazie a te lo
sanno avere
se appena usciti da casa di donato
adesso direzione bari non so come la
cosa sta facendo sono
dai facciamo così io non ho voce in
capitolo
zaia non è partito io non ha voce in
capitolo come farà a sopravvivere con
una statuetta
[Applauso]
è il coperto in importa qui scotti lo so
sarebbe stato meglio se fosse stato vero
sono già marco berry in quella villa
sono sempre superamento e la usa per
l'amica con la società di luglio
no
rosa per mia mamma
ragazzi grazie ancora in bocca al lupo
per tutto
il padre buccione culo 76 anni prendendo
che cosa facciate ma so che avete
contribuito da domani i ragazzi sia
malata del polpo e per questo panino
il colpo è la fine del mondo
un colpo al cuore la maggiore una coda
di buona dopo questo saremo già
[Musica]